what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john tell the
folks how you're doing today guys i am
better than ever before we are going to
watch today a trailer we haven't seen
like most of them we only saw the teaser
a few months ago this came out at comic
con we were focusing our attention on
other things at the time but this has
been on our mind to cover at least and
we want to cover the show when it
actually releases or like we should
check out the trailer
the lord of the rings rings of power
it's a three minute trailer i'm curious
i'm very very curious because it's
usually i liked but didn't quite knock
it out of the park for me yeah yeah this
will be much more substantial give us
something to latch on to so let's see
what's going on leave a like doesn't
take too much work the work of man
do it
we thought the war
at last
was ended
like gladreal i think so yeah hey
our days of peace
begin
is that wrong
jewelry's be unending
we thought our light
would never dim
the skies
are strange
not my frodo
the moment we feared
[Music]
evil does not sleep
evil dies tonight
beyond the darkness tempting shadow
to barriers all beneath the mountain
and i see
that
him
or oh [ __ ] more like an orc
[Music]
if the evil rising is left unchecked
it will take us off
ooh find the light
and the shadow will not find you
damn together we can survive this i
can't choose
fight with me
[Music]
each of us must decide who we shall be
[Music]
trust between hammer and rock
yeah i got some nipple chills man
sexy saurons
wow trailer was
[Laughter]
damn that was thick that was a lot of
stuff that's a lot of trailer yeah ball
rod
yes yes that's what we really care about
someone's gonna have to be given the
gand offline that's right man they're
gonna just have to do like a you know
like a more subtle delivery yeah
you shall not pass
that was a great trailer that was
beautiful that felt insanely cinematic
like the main talk surrounding this
leading up to it was not really what's
the show going to be about but just how
freaking expensive this show is
and it's all on screen it really does
show you know like the teaser it's like
this is the only other one i haven't
even seen the other ones on my own
uh the first teaser that we saw really
was like yeah it looks good um cool it's
middle earth it looks like you know
another fantasy show but it didn't feel
like there was something truly special
this feels like lord of the rings you
know this feels pure lord of the rings
an actual prequel show a series
that feels like where you could tell
something truly fresh and warranted and
and
looks better than the hobbit movies i
know there's a [ __ ]
for them hobbit movies i don't know
where they're coming from so i don't
mean to offend you this does look like
it could be better than that because it
still has the same
aesthetic and peter jackson direction
influence all over it but it still looks
like it's doing its own thing and it's
gonna definitely have to breathe more
and breathe better but the scope and
scale of it all and to actually see
galadriel's backstory because she is
kind of a
stoic character you know a wise a wise
wonder
[Music]
yeah so to see this youthful side of her
that actually feels like a character who
really could get invested in an elf
warrior who looks apparently bad like
the action looks really cool
it does and then sauron
before he was you know an all-seeing eye
or
like a super giant guy fighting in the
battles yeah that one who's just a sexy
lanky dude with a buzz cut yeah watch
him morph over time yeah you really get
to get the the presence and
understanding because what was he in the
hobbit he was just uh the necromancer
what they referred to before like a big
shadowy yeah but before you learn who he
actually is before the movie reveals who
he actually is but uh here he's going to
be an actual living breathing character
you can spend some actual time with
which i feel like could actually only
serve to further enhance the experience
of the films themselves yeah i would
hope so that's been my kind of
trepidation with this series all along
especially with things like game of
thrones i feel like we've learned that
like once you're straying from like the
really structured source material things
can go wrong sometimes we don't need an
origin on every specific character or
villain or whatever however looking at
this offering here this did get me
really pulled in and excited because a
series is a perfect environment for lord
of the rings and yes tolkien has tons
and tons of auxiliary writings i'm sure
they're borrowing from for this history
of middle earth and yeah it really does
look like a broad journey to the rise of
the situation that we meet at the
beginning of lord of the rings that is
brewing and boiling over and everything
i feel like that could be an actual
interesting story to tell rather than
just like what else can we do with the
lord of the rings world so like i'm
really pleased not to be feeling cynical
after seeing this i guess because i know
they've got the money and you know
they've got the budget to do the effects
and it does look beautiful and it does
look like they are yeah like you said
taking that jumping off point of what
peter jackson established aesthetically
but also building on it and i like that
it seems like you're spending time with
the kingdom of men you're spending time
with the dwarves the elves you know the
other creatures orcs and things that
inhabit this it feels like a whole world
here which is encouraging to me because
being not as much of a fan of the hobbit
it's like that aspect was kind of
crunched underneath the weight of all
they tried to pack onto that
so this actually has me very much
anticipating a return to uh to middle
earth and i hope they knock it out of
the park because uh they have certainly
invested in it all righty well here we
are lord of the rings bring us how are
you guys excited for this show well you
wanted to react to it here on the
channel leave your thoughts down below
we'll cram in all the books before then
yes every piece of writing every note
every discarded page we're gonna be
grand experts experts make the time
all
right really in leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell let's
end this with a patreon
rosa para happy belated birthday yes all
right we're gonna sing happy birthday to
you john's gonna sing in his deep voice
and i'm gonna sing
in my
really deep voice
yeah we'll do like a baritone harmony
ready
three two one
happy birthday
to
you
happy
birthday
to
you
[Music]
happy birthday
to you
[Music]